make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on and picking
up with New Mutants issue number three
now here's a cool thing New Mutants
issue number three actually kind of
deviates away from what we've seen so
far um instead it actually travels back
to earth and focuses on a character
named armor this is kind of interesting
right to really like bring armor
seemingly out of nowhere along with
Tabitha Smith with boom boom and then
gloves but here's the thing all right so
this initially picks up really with with
armor and and glob just kind of enjoying
krakoa right now this is a cool little
moment here it's a cool little exchange
because it's something that we don't
really see I mean we kind of saw it in
the beginning to a degree but we only
saw it in so far as it was focusing on
like the peaceful nature right really
the idea that mutants had a home but it
wasn't really focusing on like the whole
party aspect of it all and that's one of
the things that given everything and
dawn of X is easy for writers to miss
and it's it's good to see that they're
not does this there's a reason why I
like New Mutants is probably the best
story coming out of marvel at the moment
is because what you have here is you
have this scenario where armors just
sort of looking at what's going on at
the moment and everybody's just kind of
parting and have a good time look how it
looks like a blast
right it looks like the most fun ever
but and the other half of this is that
for the character of armor one of the
things she kind of longs for is some of
the members that were either part of New
Mutants or dealt with like the younger
members that really like the new mutants
themselves that weren't officially part
of the team who really aren't they're
just people she's known over the years
and people she's been friends with who
aren't really there on krakoa itself and
specifically this really comes down to
the character of Beek now there's really
sort of plays itself out where she
ghosted was its age right now Sage's our
character we've kind of talked about you
know occasionally over the course of
Marvel we've never really gone super
depth super in-depth into it we don't
really need to the nature of stage is
that her brain works like a computer
right so she never forgets information
and it categorizes it organizes that
information perfectly right so imagine
like Bradley Cooper from limitless and
that's basically sage it's one of these
things were like like Armour kind of
sits down and says well let's kind of go
through like who's who's registered and
who's not registered who's here and
who's not here right now we don't get
like a full list right Edwardson doesn't
give us like a full breakdown of
everyone right because the mutant
population while it's not as high as it
was before the events of house of M is
certainly a lot higher than it was after
the events of house of M right so
there's still thousands of mutants out
there as opposed to like the millions
that were there before and so what this
is what this would do is it would end up
being like probably like a
sighs comic rights are like a
double-sized comic works like you know I
don't know 44 pages or like 46 pages and
it would just be nothing but names it'd
be the least interesting comic book ever
whoo the fact remains that she's kind of
going through this list of people so
like Bishop of course is registered so
on and so forth but characters like beak
are not there and so what she ends up
doing is kind of say okay well like
let's go see if we can find them let's
go see if we can find these guys and so
what she ends up doing is of course
going and speaking directly with glob
and glob it's kind of a funny thing
right because one of the things he hits
on is like well everybody's have more of
a peaceful state right so people people
are really on edge and that's what are
the cool thing is to kind of take note
of and it's one of the things to
overlook this is easy to overlook when
it comes to dawn of eggs right like you
look at the nature of kokoa and despite
the death of Xavier which really sort of
caught it about the off guard different
things like that for the most part
people aren't aren't nearly as on edge
as they were before right that's one of
the big kind of tonal changes that you
noticed just going on with the x-men
right now and if you were to go and read
x-men pretty much any time before
Jonathan Hickman took it over the
overall tone of the x-men is today might
be my last day on earth and well it's
not the worst thing ever
after a while it does kind of get old as
it was good to see it kind of take a
reprieve now the reality is it took like
50 years for it to get old right so I
guess that says something about the
nature of x-men storytelling but it is
cool to kind of see an NCD see the
various mutants on earth in a position
to where they're not always like on edge
and feeling like everything is gonna
come to an end to see them just kind of
enjoying their lives right and so glog
asks the question like do you think
pixie would be into me and and it's kind
of interesting there because my thought
reading this was like dude shoot your
shot man like the worst she can do is
say no and you miss 100% of the shots
you don't take man so like walk up to
the girl and say hey like do you want to
get dinner on Friday and then like she's
gonna say yes or she's gonna say no if
she says no it's not the end of the
world if she says yes we're off to the
races Homeslice you better dress your
best man you better learn those manners
so it's it's cool to see these small
little things and this is the reason why
I say New Mutants is so cool I mean we
hit on this time and time again when it
comes to like focusing on the new mutant
team right it's it's designed to be
light hearted it's designed to be a
story word focuses on like this
struggles of teenagers and different
things like that you know these younger
kids getting out into the world and
getting out there exploring like the
dating life and falling in love and out
of love and different things like that
it's these cool little moments it's
things to kind of allow us to sort of
tap back into when we were teenagers and
to kind of look back and be like
why was I so worried about that why
would why did I think that was so
important at the time but what is up
happening here his Armour travels to
where Robert Acosta is and meets with
boom boom now at this point she doesn't
really know I guess she's kind of
figuring it out that they've basically
taken off to space you know to go hang
out with Sam Guthrie and all them so
that's what we've really covered with
New Mutants issue 1 & 2 but it's
interesting to see boom boom here right
you know boom boom is an old-school
character Tabitha Tabitha Smith she goes
back to 1985 right so she's not new she
appeared back in Secret Wars 2 I think
it was ah but she's a cure they can
create these sort of like plasma bombs
and what they do is they explode with a
concussive force and the impact of the
bombs is relative to their size right so
if it's the size of a golf ball it'll be
enough to like you know hurt you or
something like that to maybe knock you
down but if it's the size of like a
beach ball it'll punch a hole through
metal right now over the years the
ability for her to demonstrate control
over her powers it's kind of Laxton
waned and a lot of that's because the
biggest emphasis that came with boom
boom was really like with her in Richter
her Richter and a few other people as
part of my ex force and at like her time
with X Factor vectoring uh I think it
was Walter in Louise Simonson's run and
then during Rob Liefeld run on x-force
I'm not gonna swear to that after that
she's just kind of been around right and
not a whole lot has been done with her
character but she's just an old-school
character right she's a legacy character
so she's always just kind of been around
but his energy to sort of see her be
involved here because what she wants is
adventure she's bored out of her mind
she's like there's nothing to do here
she's Restless right like she longed for
that adventurous life but ultimately she
ends up settling with armor where she
basically says well let's go out and
let's go see if we can't find vegan and
these various characters and so what
this does is of course it leads to them
grabbing a couple people along the way
and then traveling out to Nebraska now
the reality was that win that win armor
told Tabitha they were gonna be going to
Nebraska it's like well that kind of
sucks and understandably so because
Nebraska only has two things going for
it nothing and the Cornhuskers it's
almost like okay you know I guess but
when they do of course they arrive at
the home of beek himself now here's the
interesting thing when it comes to be
quite a little bit of explanation here
beaky made his debut back in new x-men
issue number 117 that was really the
tail end of the es4 extinction event
where Cassandra Nova wiped out 16
million mutants in the island of Genosha
but for beak himself with his
introduction going into some of his
later appearances and new x-men it was
really focusing on the love interest
Queen himself and angel Salvatore now
eventually beat was basically taken off
off the new x-men and thrown directly
into the Exile storylines in my opinion
I really kind of felt like the Exiles
team was kind of the unsalables the
characters just that were just care just
really couldn't hold a story or really
couldn't hold their own comic or just
kind of a place to throw characters the
post house of M exile stories for
amazing right like like exiles world
tour that was amazing why when they went
to like the 2099 universe and like the
future and perfect universe it was cool
that they jumped around from reality to
reality but the issue it was really just
trying to find a place for Beek in like
the Marvel landscape at the time and
this lasted for a number of years now
eventually he returned back and actually
lost his powers for time reverted to
like a human form and then basically
took up residence with angel Salvatore
the funny thing was that when they were
both at the Xavier school he got her
knocked up she ended up getting pregnant
but basically this is just kind of the
situation where they've essentially
retreated away from kokoa
and basically taken up residence in
Nebraska and the question was why right
like why why do they ended up basically
rejecting the idea of moving to cacoa
and the reason why is because the the
father released seemingly the father of
Beek himself is dealing with Taylor
Ellis disease now I thought this was an
actual disease I looked it up apparently
it's not but it's basically in at least
in in this story as a stole it's a
really really rare version of dementia
that basically begins to just kind of
break down the body to the point where
people die exceedingly fast right like
it was named after a guy named Taylor
Ellis who died four months after
originally contracting the disease that
he ended up ended up dying from it but
that's basically what the father of
because suffering from and that's why
they chose not to go now this is cool
right this this is I mean it's not cool
that his father's dying but it's a cool
concept in so far is one of the things
that that tends to get lost when it
comes to comic books is that you sort of
see this tendency where like the
characters move from like one major
event to the next there really is no
downtime in between you don't really get
a lot of tidbits in there in terms of
like what they're doing with their own
personal life the x-men kind of doing
meaningful things or showing us what's
going on in the back end whether why
they're doing some of the things that
they're doing on a more personal level
as it was cool to see that that Beeks
character is kind of being expanded if
only so far is to show his life outside
of the x-men and why he chose not to go
to Kirk ala
that his father was basically dying and
the result was that he didn't do that
because he wanted to spend as much time
with his father as he could now the cool
thing about this is that armor shows up
it says walk but on cacoa
we have medicines that can cure this
kind of stuff
she injects it into the father of a beak
and he makes a recovery like that and
it's awesome because what this does is
it gives beak the kind of satisfaction
he was looking for and so far as his
father basically returning and then
gives them a reason to return to the
x-men it's a cool moment right it's a
it's a cool meaningful and beautiful
little moment right because like who of
us have lost a family member to
something like this and what what we
have not given to have somebody come
along with seemingly some kind of
miracle cure it takes an injection and
the world is fixed right like everything
is okay again it's a great little
relatable moment not I absolutely adore
like I think it's beautifully done the
issue with this is that once this once
this cure is applied to the father of
beat then of course once they go
upstairs the gas armor like did you
bring anybody else and she's like no and
there's just a bunch of crazy folks
outside and they basically snatched the
kids up and and like things are popping
off and it's kind of nuts here because
what this guy does is he shows up and he
says look like you guys have all these
medicines right like you mutants have
all these medicines and you've denied
them to our people so like you're gonna
give them to us now or like we're gonna
take everybody out now it's not a great
big huge thing but it's not a great big
huge earth-shattering thing it's a small
little thing but I love little moments
like this I love little stories like
this right because at most this will be
a two possibly three issue arc and
that'll be it right ladies this will
probably conclude in issue number four
if that right it'll just it'll start and
end really really quickly but I love
these small little things right because
what it shows you get these small little
conflicts that go on they're not huge
they're not like a great big crossover
right like you're not gonna see the
Avengers show up here and like help
armor against these guys there's no
reason for you to I just like these
small little things here but but it also
shows kind of how the world is dealing
with the idea that mutants are having a
far more impactful impactful approach
there because these guys show up with
like power dampening missiles it's these
cool little things right because armor
kind of jumps in she of course has the
ability to kind of create this sort of
psionic armor on herself that's actually
pretty powerful I guess it's pretty
durable in terms of how she impacts and
how she deals with various other people
out there but it's like a small little
skirmish and what we're likely gonna see
here is kind of a display of what it is
a beast capable of and the reason why
that matters is because historically
speaking because a character who has
never really taken seriously as that's
why it's gonna be a small little thing
right because people basically be able
to kind of come out here fight alongside
the other mutants who are there and it's
gonna be at vs. Way of saying hey like
here's why beat Matt errs here's what
his powers are here's what he's capable
of em
like this is why he'd be an interesting
addition to the x-men and most likely
it'll be the reason why he ends up
returning so it's a cool moment but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain it make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the Rob port if you guys want to see
my uncensored and vs. videos head over
the patreon.com slash comments explained
and if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Jason s
Austin H Phillip and Austin B we have
lot of Austin's and our patreon as well
as G gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us
a first and last name so we kinda had to
roll with it I didn't mention your last
names after you guys didn't want me to
throw them out there but I want to say
thank you to you all by the way your
rob4 rings should be on their way for
our honor guard members of the rob corps
for these special patrons your custom
rob core rings should be on their way
they're being shipped to me after that I
will have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon in your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]